tell me a story just a quick story about
Bill Paxton that you remember that from
working with him because and and how
were you close with him and how did him
passing affect you well uh bill and I
did a movie called Lord's discipline
together that's where I met Bill and
Bill is a live wire
bill is uh he comes into a room and you
know it a lot of fun uh very passionate
knows films well uh I had worked at
Roger corman's company with with Jim
Cameron uh I did five movies with him so
I knew bill before he met Louise uh
and when he met Louise when when we were
uh right at the end of Lords of
discipline and then we went over and did
um aliens together that was the greatest
time uh that I had with Bill I mean uh
you know next time you have me on I'll
tell you uh because it's about a 10
minute story or maybe in I could cut it
down but to really do it justice and
really to do to do Bill Justice uh you
know I'll come back but he was
um uh I've he he he he seemed to enjoy
life more than other people he seemed to
like eat life and you know this smile
and he was always kind of bigger than
life
and as an actor he got started off that
way and he was so great in Aliens for
being that's a little bit like Bill
Paxton without the coward part okay
that's a little bit like who Bill Paxton
was but throughout the years he was able
to bring that down and by the time he
was working with Billy Bob Thornton and
doing his television series for HBO he
was just a really good actor and his
being hired was not based on uh his
personality but he he he's an infectious
infectious person personality who um uh
I spent uh well I spent a couple yeah I
I didn't know him as well uh before uh
you know I saw him on the 25th
anniversary of aliens and we were
talking a little bit and he started to
talk to me about his something to do
with his heart and I was listening
because I've had open heart surgery
that's another
he's coming back Ryan don't you worry
open heart Bill Paxton stories he's
coming back go ahead he's telling you
about his heart yeah well he started
talking to me about his heart and I've
got um
Rico simonini is my cardiologist one of
the best in the in in the country and uh
I I had my heart surgery done by a guy
named Bud Frazier who's more used to
doing heart transplant mine was a one
foot Putt and something I was no it was
I was born with a regurgitating valve or
a heart murmur so I've had it my whole
life but I got to be 55
52 or 3 or whatever it was it was so
right after
I had my stroke I don't know it was
before you know whatever but anyway he's
telling you about his heart so he
started talking to me about his heart
and somebody pulled me away and so I
never had the conversation with him
because I would immediately said to him
you got to talk to my guy Rico he's the
best in the business I've had it you
know he was aware of that and I think he
probably wanted to talk to me about it
Bill uh went to uh Cedars-Sinai and was
operated on and uh
uh my opinion is that they butchered him
and uh I think that his family felt that
way they filed a lawsuit against Cedars
which was
um uh uh finally it was supposed to go
to court last December and they finally
settled out of court uh it was a very
simple surgery what what he was doing
and he had a doctor that uh uh
[Applause]
well according to Bell street according
to Bill's family he uh uh made a lot of
mistakes and I had a little bit of
inside knowledge on
on what happened and uh here's the thing
about it is
um you know we've all got a uh uh a date
with our name on it and bills happened
to be that he nobody could have enjoyed
life more than Bill nobody could have
had more fun nobody could have loved as
much as he did
um nobody could have been a better
father uh he's he was human you know he
he and I used to get into some trouble
together so he was human but uh uh one
of the uh uh
hi and I kind of took him on as a
younger brother because I had worked
more at the time so I I would I felt
like I I helped him become from an
acting standpoint he used to go to a
acting coach that I first started with
the name Vincent Chase and he stayed
with Vincent Chase right up until he
died but he didn't he didn't need to die
but
you know none of us need to die were you
very upset about it it really impact you
yeah
I yeah I uh
just because
you know we're all gonna die but
when it happens like that you know when
it happens because of violence or
because of somebody making a mistake or
somebody's hubris and thinking no I'm
gonna try it this way and uh
it makes it makes it more difficult and
um you know more than anything else
um uh I miss him you know